when I first saw the original Little
Mermaid my whole world changed
like so many of us little girls we all
just wanted to be mermaids
I think the little mermaid is an iconic
powerful story it was important to
expand and make it a fuller experience
it's Little Mermaid reflects what it
means to want something greater for
yourself
voice
so emotional she set the bar and no one
ever surpassed me poor child I've been
watching you for a long time now too
Melissa McCarthy as Ursula she's
extraordinary she's so dishy and
conniving we got a deal I mean I'll just
give you the premium package kid she's
hilarious and terrifying true
is
The Little Mermaid was the first film I
ever scored it's especially emotional
coming back and with lin-manuel Miranda
who was so brilliant the songs we've
written expand what little mermaid is I
feel really proud to work on The Little
Mermaid because these characters live in
my heart
I don't know where I don't know how but
I know something's starting right now
the world that Rob Marshall created
precious boundaries he's doing something
special
just a dream come true
[Music]